this is the one year anniversary of a
deadly military takeover in myanmar the
southeast asian nation once known as
burma hundreds of demonstrators were
killed by troops that were sent into
cities to break up protests against the
coup it was just the beginning of a
fight that's still raging one year later
elizabeth palmer met some of the people
trying to win it
the lush thai countryside just across
the river from myanmar shelters refugees
from a fight they didn't pick
everyone from buddhist monks to
political activists taking refuge from
myanmar's military which seized power a
year ago today
but when the general sent the army into
the streets they didn't expect this
[Applause]
furious protesters ready to defend their
fragile democracy but it was a wrap the
army opened fire on the protesters and
hundreds were killed
so this is your new home yes
jaw say y'all was there
at that time they are
shooting at anywhere
he wasn't shot but he was arrested
what did they do to you they beat me
six or seven soldiers with what with
sticks
shoes
wire
now he's settled in a safe house in the
thai border town of my sop with his
family including his brother-in-law
maya too was a captain in myanmar's army
but he deserved it
i couldn't serve anymore he told me
because it was hurting civilians
inside myanmar some democracy activists
have now turned to violence
security cameras filmed this one tossing
a grenade into a police station
in the jungle young people are
volunteering for military training with
myanmar's armed ethnic groups
while on the thai side captain two is
pitching in so you tell people what to
look for
and what equipment they might have with
his ipad teaching military tactics
online
[Applause]
myanmar's elected leader was arrested by
the generals and she's now facing life
in jail a year on myanmar's democracy is
definitely down but millions of brave
citizens are trying to make sure it's
not out
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer my
salt